ça remonte à plusieurs mois en arrière
nous étions quatre quatre policiers
aguerris ayant au moins une bonne
dizaine d'années d'expérience tous les
uns comme les autres
nous étions pas troué habituellement
donc ambiance qui en général dans un
véhicule de police est plutôt bonne et
subitement
on a vu deux individus sur un scooter
125 centimètres cubes qui avait toutes
les caractéristiques d'un scooter
signalée volée donc il n'ya pas de
plaque d'immatriculation
et et deux individus qui étaient casqués
dessus donc notre expérience nous a
permis
d'aller à leur contact sans mettre leur
vie en danger parce que l'aîné vida
manquant dans ce type d'intervention on
a peur évidemment pour nous mais aussi
pour les autres et rapidement le
conducteur a été interpellé par mes
soins en compagnie de collègues qui
étaient présents ce moment là tandis que
le passager lui prenait la fuite dans le
département limitrophe puisque nous
étions limite de département donc
automatiquement mes deux collègues qui
sont partis en courant derrière le
passager se sont rapidement trouvés dans
un quartier qui ne connaissait pas
puisque c'était par leur département
officiel dans lequel les officiels il
travaillait
ils ont été
accueillis par une bande d'individus
donc les collègues lors de leurs
auditions signalés entre 20 à 30
individus
ils ont décidé de faire demi tour parce
qu'ils sont dit ça sert à rien de
prendre des risques
le passage est bon il risquera pas grand
chose au niveau pénal mais on a conduit
tant que tout va bientôt ils décident de
faire marche arrière et de robots de
revenir sur leurs pas sauf que les
individus les en ont empêchés alors ils
ont entouré ils les ont entourées ils
les ont menacés alors au début
la chose a été plutôt clair et mes
collègues avaient leur brassard certains
émettaient des doutes sur le fait que ce
soit de réelles policiers donc les
collègues ont essayé de prendre la fuite
en courant mais sont fait rapidement
rattrapé par ces individus moi de mon
côté je faisais prendre en charge m'ont
interpellé par un autre véhicule de
police est rapidement avec mon chauffeur
je me transportait sur les lieux sur les
lieux sauf que
sur les ondes de radio ils ne savaient
pas où ils étaient donc il ne pouvait
pas dire exactement où il se trouvait et
quand je les ai eus au téléphone ça a
été ça a été horrible ça a été léger
quoi tout ce que vous avez passé dix
minutes au téléphone avec eux leurs
factures piège j'étais au téléphone avec
un de mes deux équipiers
pendant plus de dix minutes vous n'avez
faim qui avaient ils ont clairement eu
peur pour l'herbe pour leur vie sont dit
on va je peux vous dire que à ce moment
là vous entendez des appels au secours
de la part de vos collègues vous
entendez des cris vous entendez plein de
choses et on demandait mais vous êtes
tous vous êtes tous deux mois une longue
rue c'est de me donner un numéro quelque
chose et il criait tellement fort dans
le téléphone que j'ai c'est qu'on était
avec mon chauffeur incapable de
déchiffrer le nom de rue qui nous
donnait donc on était totalement paniqué
on tournait avec le gyrophare allumé
actionnée dans les rues en essayant de
deux mâts de les trouver par par chance
ça a duré dix minutes et dix minutes au
cours desquelles
j'ai entendu mon collègue à deux
reprises de dire les gars je suis désolé
j'ai pas le choix j'ai pas le choix et
la deux coups de feu deux coups de feu
donc avec mon chauffeur on se regarde on
continue à crier à tourner et c'est un
bon chauffeur étaient pris de panique il
sortait par la fenêtre du véhicule en
mouvement et il criait tu es août et où
enfin c'était c'était vraiment j'en ai
encore dans le coeur serré et il de
savoir que c'est son collègue a fait
usage de son arme
sans savoir dans quel cadre légal bon
jeu on n'était pas sur place mais on
suppose qu'ils étaient dans le cadre de
la légitime défense est-ce que ça va pas
engendrer derrière des répercussions
pénale
et puis est ce que les collègues sont
pas baissé en sons se pose pas une
question en ce moment là et
quelques secondes avait passé en fait
pourquoi il attirait bien tout
simplement parce que en fait il a voulu
extirper le collègue qui était en train
de se faire molester par les deux
individus lui avait encore un peu plus
d'énergie donc il a pu courir sauf qui
s'est vite rendu compte qu'il était seul
donc il est revenu chercher l'autre
collègue et c'est à ce moment là qu'il
avait il n'avait pas d'autre choix en
fait il s'est dit cc où je tire ou a dit
roman l'air il attire il a tiré au sol
d'accord au sol il a tiré au sol il
s'est posé la question est ce que je
suis en légitime défense est-ce que je
peux tirer et il a quand même pris eu la
présence d'esprit de le dire je ne peux
pas tirer je vais pas ôter la vie de
quelqu'un
champy je tire au sol
alors ç'a eu l'effet que ça hue
tout de suite après il ya eu deux autres
coups de ceux qui ont été tirées donc en
tout il y en a eu quatre et je peux vous
dire que nous à ce moment là on entend
les quatre coups de feu on dit mais
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se
passe et par chance
abandonné dans une rue des gens nous
font signe nous font signe d'aller dans
une direction on y va et quand on arrive
sur le la fameuse place où ça se passait
on a vu une scène de chaos moi je vois
mon collègue avec son arme à la main
totalement paniqué il allait dans tous
les sens s'ils savaient plus où aller
ils criaient il se tenait la tête et
quelques mètres à côté il y avait mon
deuxième collègue qui lui était en train
de se faire boxer simplement que c'était
le terme il y avait un individu plus
particulièrement pour visiter plusieurs
et donné des coups de pied et puis
reculer mais en avait un plus
particulièrement kg tenait qu'il boxait
qui le boxeur qu'il a boxé et quand on
voit ça quand on a vécu on a entendu
pendant plus de dix minutes
les appels au secours la détresse les
cris de nos collègues plus les coups de
feu on a au fond de soi un sentiment de
de rage tout simplement vos collègues
ils sont forcément aux traumatisés ont
repris le service alors il y en a qui
l'y a repris
dernièrement avant-hier restait combien
de temps sans ben il est resté huit mois
en a mais d'accord mais et le deuxième
qui a tiré les coups de feu il reste
encore traumatisé il sait pas trop s'il
va rester dans la police parce que pour
lui il estime qu'aujourd'hui est
policier prendre des risques comme ça
c'est un métier de chien simple c'est un
métier de chien
alors je vais aller côté évidemment vous
avez été énormément marqué aussi j'ai
été j'ai été avec mon chauffeur qui n'a
pas pu venir ce soir malheureusement
j'ai été très marqué
avec ce qui s'est passé ça nous a encore
plus soudés les uns les autres mais de
voir son collègue en train de se faire
prendre des coups au visage avec le
visage tuméfié quand on arrive sur place
il est le visage complètement tuméfié il
est sonné il sait même plus où il est le
saint juif et l'autre collègue qu'il
hurle qui est qu'il désigne en même
temps c'est lui c'est lui il faut le
rattraper moigne unis deux avec mon
collègue on s'est rapproché les
individus a forcément pris la fuite
quand ils nous ont vus arriver un ni
deux je suis sorti de la voiture j'ai
pris ma gazeuse à la main et j'ai couru
derrière les 20 individus qui courait à
travers la cité pour prendre la fuite et
et c'est après coup je me suis rendu
compte mais qu'est ce que tu as fait
thierry tu cours dans une cité que tu ne
connais pas derrière 20 individus qui
ont tenté de le tuer ou en tout cas de
violente et qui ont violenté tes
collègues et tu coures derrière eux et
aujourd'hui gens sur ces moments-là on
réfléchit pas aussi on fait ça c'est ça
et après coup j'en suis quand même
plutôt satisfait parce que je me dis que
c'était la moindre des choses que je
pouvais faire pour mes collègues ils
peur d'aller sur le terrain maintenant
il ya toujours cette appréhension de
plus en plus noir énormément énormément
énormément énormément énormément parce
que on va pas se cacher on vit quand on
vit dans une société qui est de plus en
plus sur médiatisées où les gens sont
systématiquement en train de se demander
s'ils peuvent faire le buzz en filmant
une scène quoi et nous on veut tout
simplement faire notre travail sauf que
quand on arrive à un moment donné ou où
les gens nous filme en nouveautés en
dénonçant des faits pour lesquels ils
n'ont même pas été témoin mais parce
qu'ils nous voient nous rouler par terre
avec des individus qu'on veut tout
simplement interpellé
écrit à la bavure policière alors qu'ils
ne savent même pas ce qui s'est passé et
enfin moi j'ai tout simplement un j'ai
un sentiment de rage tout simplement pas
ces injustices
alors la justice
elle est trop laxiste justice pour vous
pas oui oui elle est trop l'accès se
fait justice bien entendu pour moi je
sais j'en reviens ce que je disais tout
à l'heure avec mon collègue qui disait
qu'il allait peut-être changer de boulot
parce qu'il a estimé que c'est un
travail de chien on prend énormément de
risques si ça
on prend énormément de risques pour que
derrière au final les individus
interpellés soient relaxés enfin relâché
avec du sursis et on les retrouve
quelques mois plus tard en train de
commettre d'autres méfaits et d'ailleurs
j'ai une petite anecdote à ce sujet là
c'est que
il ya moins d'un mois nous étions
en prise en charge peut pas dire qu'on
se poursuite derrière un scooter de très
grosses cylindrées qui était signalé
volé et on a réussi à interpeller
l'individu donc été en possession de
matière stupéfiante sur le scooter
signalée volée et quelle a été ma
stupeur lorsque je n'ai vu lorsque j'ai
ôté le casque de cet individu lorsque
j'ai constaté que celui-ci faisait
partie des six interpellés dans la
sphère de
régression de mes collègues six mois en
arrière ah ouais voilà donc ça confirme
tout simplement que un jour les mêmes
qui sont identifiés de même un gros
atout manie version connue c'était vite
cessé assas moi ça fait ça fait 16 ans
que j'ai dans la police a fait 10 ans
que je suis en bac départementale
j'adore mon métier moi je suis répond ça
arrêtez vous oui plusieurs fois oui
j'arrive à 40 ans j'ai trois enfants
qu'ils soient liés à la peur pour
mes enfants sont fiers ouais mais ils
grandissent ils commencent à avoir de
l'ag se rendre compte que c'est de plus
en plus dangereux ça fait énormément je
termine mon service à 20h quand je les
appelle à 21h30 pour leur dire que papa
il va pas rentrer tout de suite parce
qu'il faut qu'il aille déposer plainte
faut qu'il aille voir un médecin pour
faire constater ses blessures et il n'y
a pas plus tard qu une semaine c'est
encore arrivé un individu qui avait un
mandat de recherche pour des faits de
vol avec arme
cet individu s'est rebellé et derrière
lorsque nous étions au sol pour le
maîtriser on a eu cinq six individus
amis de 2,2 du premier qui venaient nous
met des coups de pied des coups de pompe
des coups de poing dans le dos pour vous
faire lâcher prise et encore une semaine
j'étais encore au tribunal en train de
me justifier sur les violences dont j'ai
été victime que j'ai suivi la situation
et les pires qu'avant
j'ai 40 ans ça fait 16 ans que dans la
police placez la situation évolue et l
es gens et j'entends les anciens et les
anciens sont unanimes pour dire
qu'effectivement la situation est pire
qu'avant beaucoup place et que la
société beaucoup plus violent le cap il
ya plus de respect de la police
également way non il n'ya plus de
retenue on l'a vu et c'est vrai que tous
ces policiers est ou sebha que sont déjà
d'expérience d'abord évidemment on peut
pas la faire là bas comme ça en sortant
de l'école de police n'est pas possible
mais quand on écoute seront son
témoignage on se rend compte quand même
que ces gars là et je me demande même
comme il ya pas de mort très sincèrement
c'est le cas on attend ce garçon être
pris à partie tabasser sortir son arme
avoir la présence d'esprit de faire un
tir de dissuasion c'est à dire tiré par
terre ou en l'air pour faire partir ces
gens là mais je sais pas comment moi
j'aurais réagi j'ai quand même pas mal
d'expérience de la police je ne sais pas
quand même donc je dis bravo mais je
suis effaré d'entendre ce que je
n'entende pas c est malheureusement
c'est presque du quotidien de ce que dit
notre ami jerry ya des endroits où vous
n'allez plus alors le risque la police
que je connais moi personnellement va
partout et par tous d'accord elle va
partout si les gens appellent pour
signaler des trafiquants de drogue la
police yvan la police y va elle
n'emploie pas forcément les mêmes
méthodes et les mêmes moyens que dans
d'autres quartiers mais la police fait
son travail en tout cas la présence
policière elle est effective dans toutes
les zones
si c'est le département où j'officie et
jeu excusez moi je suis ému je
je je tiens vraiment à
hassi niasse a souligné il a remercié
tous les membres des forces de l'ordre
parce que je n'oublie pas les gendarmes
jeudi par les policiers en tenue qu'il
faut policiers municipaux des policiers
municipaux qui font leur travail
qui sont là pour sauver la veuve et
l'orphelin c'est un peu un peu l'image
est ce que je fais ce que je dis mais
mais faut pas croire que la police
notamment la bac
n'intervient que sur les trafics de
drogue dans le cycle oui effectivement
ça fait partie du lot quotidien des
policiers mais lorsqu'il ya des appels
17 pour signaler des agressions sur la
voie publique est bien là bas qui va et
les policiers y vont et les policiers
interpellent très très souvent les
auteurs de ces agressions et en tout cas
travaille dans le sens des victimes
c'est vraiment la rage clause de
solidarité entre vous quand on a vécu
des événements comme çà çà çà çà çà
souder les liens effectivement je sais
que j'ai régulièrement
mon collègue qui a tiré les quatre coups
de feu en ligne n'a pas repris et n'a
toujours pas repris sain il n'a toujours
pas repris il est censé reprendre dans
bientôt mais il se pose la question il
dit je me vois pas je viens d'avoir une
petite fille je ne vois pas continuer à
travailler de cette façon prendre des
risques pour rien